[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's featured webinar on
analytical validation and performance
verification key components for ivdr
compliance i'm bill and leicher from
thermo fisher scientific and i'd like to
introduce today's speaker raphael
ramirez
raphael is the global business
development manager at thermo fisher
scientific for professional services in
this role raphael works with users in
regulated laboratories and identifies
ways to enable those users to comply
with their regulatory requirements
throughout his career he has specialized
in qualification and validation services
particularly computer system validation
and analytical validation consulting
services
he has assisted pharma biopharma and
clinical laboratories across the globe
to meet their compliance needs
please join me in welcoming rafael
right thank you bill
um so we'll be discussing um medical
validation we'll
briefly touch also on performance
certifications
but of course we are looking at
the ibdr uh regulation uh in the
european union so that'll be kind of the
framework but we'll see be referencing
some standards from other regions um i
will see how those play i think that's
important to set up as a as a background
so a little of the agenda
we'll go through an introduction on um
analytical validation uh do a little bit
of background as well
the challenge is to complete analytical
validation so we'll type
deep type on on these um
what it takes to do a consolidation
talk about key personnel uh it's
important as laboratories plan to set up
for this um it's important they have the
right personnel
in place um and then ultimately uh from
our perspective how we help customers
with the um unrequited validation
services that we offer
so let's look at the article validations
it is a process it is globally found
within quantity standards and
in the european union specifically the
ivdr says sea regulation and critical
laboratories must follow in order to
offer certain regulated services um the
ibdr
then points to um certain iso more
specifically the iso 1345 from the
international standards organization and
the iso of 5189 which is the quality
standard for testing within um clinical
laboratories
these standards in turn require
laboratories to ensure their testing are
validated right so
first we have the regulation that needs
to have that says that laboratories must
comply with certain quality standards um
then these quality standards in turn
have
a little bit more specifically
call that many services need to be
validated
in the case of commercially available
tests those will be registered by the
manufacturer with the notified bodies um
and uh to do this
the manufacturers themselves need to
comply with the same um standards the
iso 1345 and the iso
5189 um so the the laboratories that um
independent laboratories that wish to do
um in-house develop tests and offer this
uh for um
as one of their services
they need to comply with the same level
of requirements
so what we have done is look at
various international standards and then
found
we actually found
some a number of similarities between
this um clssi the clinical laboratory
standard
institute defines the validation as a
provision of objective evidence through
a defined process that it says performs
as intended
the international standard organization
iso defines validation as a process of
confirmation using objective evidence to
confirm that requirements within which
define a specific intended use or
application have fulfilled have been
fulfilled so
we see they're using different language
but ultimately they are pretty much
given the same
expectations of
getting objective evidence and looking
towards the intended use
of that particular test
so different countries as nations
through legislation said the regulations
for clinical testing um in the
european union we have the ivdr the ibd
regulation um in the united states then
we have um the clinical laboratory
improvement amendments um known as clia
uk has ukca
china has their own so again different
nations different
countries will have
these regulations at a legislative level
um so verification a little bit
different
but it's still globally recognized now
in this case um the process and we'll
use the definition from the nist
is the provision of objective evidence
that a given
item for field specified requirements
now we're not looking towards um
intended use in this case that we're
still collecting objective evidence but
now we're looking at requirements that
have been set for the implementation of
that particular
assay in this case as as clinical tests
so let's uh
talk about a little bit more in detail
now on analytical validation so what is
an analytical pollination
and there are two critical aspects uh
during an analytical pollination
one of them is the documentation and the
second is the collection of tangible
evidence so we immediately see how this
ties back to those standards set by
those international organizations
the the documentation
setting up validation plan setting up
reports on on the uh
objective evidence has been collected um
tangible evidence uh of course we need
to um
look at the data uh analyze that data
report on that data that goes back to
documentation
but it also has to be
developed in a way that that fits the uh
the intended use right so what's the
criteria of what we want to do
with this
analytical
validation um so when is it necessary
the article validation is
mostly evident evidently necessary
before adding a new test to a clinical
menu um
laboratories might be conscious
of after they have a set
assay um there can be changes right so
they can have different chemistry they
can have new instrumentation they can
add targets uh to their to their panels
so those different um uh
variations or deviations from the
original um validated assay they need to
be assessed and they need to re-evaluate
it could require full revalidation could
require just doing a study and document
the different
process and the results compared those
results but ultimately the important
part is that there has to be that
revalidation
so
um as we said let's look at it a bit of
the background
other areas that have
legislation and have
quality standards and they have
guidelines in place so we use this as a
reference when we
discuss a little bit further on ivdr so
we look in this case at the united
states they have clinical laboratory
improvement amendments um sclea was
established in 1988 by the u.s congress
and the clear then became the regulation
by which clinical laboratories comply
in order to offer clinical services
the college of american pathologists
known as escap
they set out to develop the guidelines
that uh allow laboratories to meet then
the clia
requirements so together they're
formally known as capclea
but
they're even others within the united
states uh very well known um new york
state department of health um they have
their own guidelines for clinical
laboratories
in this case um they're enforced by the
new york city department of health um
they're considered to be more stringent
that keplia
but we'll see once we actually break
them down there's still similarities
between this um so even regionally we
see a little bit of variations on uh
what laboratories need to do to be in
compliance and offer clinical services
in a particular
area so um
in in the case of
ngs
some epic panels um ngs is actually i'm
sorry um new york state is actually well
known because they have a very specific
requirements in this case so that's
that's simply a good point to uh to look
at it a little bit more detail
so
besides the the clinical requirements uh
for for labrador or the requirements for
clinical laboratories
as a national requirement medical
devices in the united states they must
comply with the 510k um regulation or
submit under 510k
by the fda and then get approval
to be a commercial available uh products
so
different areas but again very similar
when we look at uh what other regions do
compared to to the ivdr
so as i mentioned let's break down a
little bit more this um guidelines and
regulations set out by clia
guidelines by cap
and and again um
regulations from the uh from the new
york state
um in this case uh clear for example
they include accuracy precision vehicle
sensitivity analytical uh specificity
a few others um these are the assay
performance characteristics
that they have established that
need to be um evaluated need to be
reported um and that will be part of
that um analytical validation of an of
an essay um
some of these guidelines um again new
york states a little bit more specific
they actually give a number of samples
that need to be run i got clia does the
same um but again
the the performance characteristics
as you see on just on this line
they're very similar among all of these
so
that really help us to start seeing we
can we can
build some general uh approach uh to
analytical validation and really
leverage um those similarities to be
able to service across regions and
across um
different areas uh to again be able to
offer um analytical validation service
so within professional thermo fisher
professional services
we have used this and to develop a very
robust
validation consulting service that they
can easily be adapted to different
regions and even locally to different um
requirements
now um
back to
ivdr and and
the requirements within the the european
union
as we mentioned before they point to iso
15189 as a quality guideline for
clinical laboratory
analytical validations um now in this
case it's not as specific as maybe some
others that
we discussed previously
um
but in this particular case then we can
look at
how do we uh
what performance characteristics
performance parameters
are set out in other validation
guidelines and then we can see those um
and see those fits within
what um iso 5189
requires so we can leverage from other
international guidelines look at those
similarities
and then recommend parameters so in this
case we we recommend accuracy
representability repeatability uh
control known relevant interference
analytical sensitivity analytical
specificity and lod or limit of
detection um so
those will be very robust
to then fulfill the requirements under
iso 15 189 so what other
to keep in mind is
the performance verification right so um
essays are already validated um either
as in-house
a developed test um or commercial
available
products um the laboratories must show
that they can perform
and and meet the
parameters um and the specifications for
those particular assets so performance
certification is always
necessary before doing actual
testing
let's move on now into
the actual av
experience the theoretical validation
and and what it takes to uh to complete
an analytical validation and
it can be an overwhelming process um
not only for inexperienced uh
laboratories but
because um more clearly for an
experienced laboratory um they will have
a bigger challenge at completing
validation um but even larger
laboratories experienced laboratories uh
when they have competing
responsibilities completing projects
going on um it can be uh overwhelming
and it can just delay
um the process
so um key areas that uh we have
identified are critical to be successful
with analytical validation uh one of
them is the the pre-validation planning
um
data analysis um is also another uh
time-consuming aspect of the validation
and and ultimately by a
robust bioinformatics report so as we
discussed early on um documentation very
critical tangible evidence so in order
to have good tangible evidence uh we
need to prepare for that that's part of
the pre-validation planning um
documentation not only on that privilege
and planning and setting a good
validation plan but then also on that
bioinformatics report or that i report
at the very end
when we go through all the
bioinformatics analysis
on pre-validation planning and
laboratories must consider whether they
have the right controls in place
different assays different targets
can require different
controls so
some questions to ask yourselves as
laboratory managers military directors
do i have protocols in place to
efficiently execute the validation right
that's called part of that pre-planning
um what acceptance criteria and bounds
are are analytically appropriate to have
a good robust tangible evidence and a
good report um for this uh validation so
all of this should be uh part of that
planning should be completed before
starting any uh testing we don't want to
start tests and then find out that we
don't have a good representative set of
data
or we don't have the right control so we
are not getting what we expect out of
the um the data on these results
so again very critical that pre-planning
aspect of it um
that analysis um next-generation
sequencing in particular creates very
large data sets um so i
can vary depending on the assay being
validated
many laboratories may not have the right
bioinformatics resources right so
it is important to make that assessment
and be very objective internally
if we have
the right resources for that
also we have the time again there are
large sets of data um it will take some
time to analyze review compile summarize
um all these analytical data and also
the experience
do we have the experience of analyzing
this type of data
so
when these elements are considered
validated confirmed front
that leads to a successful validation a
partner within uh with an experienced
team
experts on the iom platform
part of what
the thermal scientific team offers
can be the difference between a quick
successful engagement or month-long
frustrating experience
so let's uh kind of look at
once again breaking down um what it
takes to have biological validation now
we're looking at um the resources that
we identify right so we are addressing
that click planning preplanning we're
addressing that data analysis
the bioinformatics reports so there are
three
resources tasks and that we feel are are
critical uh for again that successful
engagement um so when we look at these
uh critical elements in validation we
can identify people right that can do
this um an experienced project manager
will help in identifying the right
controls to use
um ensure the controls are properly
characterized that we have we're
addressing the right targets for this
that we have a proper evaluation plan
in place
that we are preparing towards a
solid and robust report
now on the bioinformatics piece um again
can be dancing um particularly for for
an experienced people on a particular
assay but
in reality uh when we are in most cases
validating an assay is because it is a
new offering within that laboratory so
again uh that assessment um very honest
assessment of having that experience is
critical so
once we have all of this there is one
last piece that uh we feel is is
critical um which is the um the
application itself right so um having
the expertise um and experience to run
um this assay uh having the proper
training um on the platform
that is very critical so from the
manufacturer side um the application
scientist
plays a very important role
commonly laboratories
will need to have support from that uh
trained application experts um they
these experts ensure
um the staff is comfortable with the
implementation of the assay with running
the assay and the and equipment so
during the analytical validation testing
um there could be questions there could
be situations where um the the
laboratory staff needs to reach out and
get support from
the manufacturer so being and having
priority access
to these resources and really making
sure that you can count on them
is essential to keep everything on track
and potentially avoid weeks delay
so now we're looking at what we
can offer from from a thermal feature a
professional services perspective
we looked at
the regulations we look at the
international quality standards
we look at the experience from
customers and even within our team
our professional services team that has
experience with this we look at how we
can build an invalid proposition and in
this case we feel that time costs and
compliance those are the three main
areas
that will make an impact for for
laboratories
from a time perspective having a project
manager that really keeps the focus on
the on the validation um that is not
subject to those competing priorities
within the day-to-day management of a of
a laboratory um is is critical um it can
be
costly um in terms of time when when we
don't have that um but then also when we
look at sourcing the controls right that
was another area that we
look at um being able to properly
address that to have the proper controls
the proper set of samples um
it reduces those costs right and keep
control on that aspect that can quickly
escalate and final understanding the
validation strategy that speeds between
the quality requirements is critical
so as we saw before there are number of
similarities but really targeting that
particular compliance
it is essential so our team has many
years of collective experience in
article validation including
bioinformatics and project management so
this allows us to quickly deploy and run
through analytical validation um
inventory of uh controls uh knowing up
front since we know the the assays and
the panels uh what
controls work best for that particular
sam panel um that again helps with
keeping everything on track and
limiting the
excessive cost
and once again the efficiency of having
that project management
guidance
really keeps everything on track so with
a variable and evolving compliance
environments um having this overall
support um that's really critical in
being successful in a
analytical validation
thermo fisher
large organization we have
many different functional areas but
within this team of professional
services
we want to integrate everything right
and we work with the rest of the
organization one thing that is critical
and this is why we have four pillars
that guide our service um one of them is
is transparency um everything that we do
on a day-to-day basis here is uh
communication with the customers so
every time we engage on an article
validation service um we're
communicating with the customer making
recommendations um listening to their
questions and finding those answers for
them
and then what our integrated support um
comes
into play
is to have access to the application
sciences is to have access to
service engineers
and and have all that experience
be able to optimize the workflow for the
customer having access also to the
development teams again all of that
comes together to really um optimizing
that workflow and giving the best um
overall perspective towards um dynamical
validation um in terms of flexibility
it's something that we have to do right
understanding their variations um
even within the
european union and the ibdr once the um
modified bodies are in place and and
they are also um giving directions more
locally
we can see differences so we have to be
sensitive
to each particular country even within
the ivdr
larger regulation
we need to be flexible and understand
those differences
and ultimately technical acumen
we have constant training
our teams are are our experts on what
they do right so um
we definitely
want to leverage that collective
experience
to be able to service our customers the
best we can
so
this is a little bit of of a perspective
of um
what happens in a laboratory right when
we are talking about um adding a new uh
clinical test within a laboratory's menu
um
that has a goal of ultimately being able
to go into routine service into rooting
testing so the faster we do that the
faster and the laboratory really sees a
return on that initial investment of
purchasing new equipment or potentially
even a new platform
for that laboratory purchasing that new
assay so we want to accelerate that
process to really be able to allow the
laboratory to fulfill um their mission
and see the return on on that initial
investment so um shortening that
analytical validation time frame it is
one critical aspect that we can bring in
to uh support a larger
goal from clinical laboratories
what's included with the um analytical
validation service um we have
exclusively talked about uh the project
management part of this um so dedicated
project management is part of the
service um
application
scientist support uh from a clinical
perspective clinical application
scientists uh those are
part of the um the team uh that delivers
in recall validation so they will make
sure that um
the workflow the uh
the
staff laboratory staff is uh properly
trained and comfortable again with
implementing the the assays um and then
ultimately that technical review of um
all the data that is being collected
right so we discussed that includes the
validation plan that's one of the actual
deliverables we provide as say as a
template for
the laboratory we have consultations on
what's included on that template
and what that means for for the
laboratory going through um the report
in the same manner once we have all the
data
the analysis that is done uh with the
data then we have a consultation of what
is being
identified and what's being uh what
comes out out of those um
validation test runs right um so all of
that is is a uh happens on a consecutive
basis with the customer every
week or so there is a call with the
laboratory staff to make sure we have
that constant communication
so we have developed again looking at
flexibility and and what um
different laboratories different needs
can they can have
different levels of service um but
ultimately
as consulting service we can adapt any
of this but as a general guidance right
so um some laboratories they they may
just want to have
a
pre-validation
assessment and see how they are doing um
and before engaging in a
formal analytical validation so for that
we have a performance verification
service um that service also has
serves as we discussed for
validated or commercially available
essays
we can do a performance certification as
well and walk the customer through that
process um the analytical validation
regional
now it's a larger scale now it's a
complete um validation we are targeting
under the iso 5189 as everything we
discussed very early on in this
conversation um with a dedicated project
manager uh supplying the controls
documentation templates
several weeks engagement depending on
particular assay that it's being worked
on
but it goes through all that process as
we defined before
of pre-planning
selecting the the right controls and
samples um designing the appropriate
test runs with representative data
towards uh what we want to
demonstrate and collect that tangible
evidence
that analysis and then finally um a
report on that that we collectively uh
consult with the customer on uh put it
together in a uh
in a report
ultimately we have um a analytical
validation service um that is more
specific if some customers want to
still uh need more specific requirements
such as
caplia
clssi
or new york state department of health
so even outside the u.s we sometimes
find those requests we have a service
site specific
for that for that need
so there are a number of different
assets and panels
that
some of future scientific offers
we have successfully have
engagements on uh supporting customers
and consulting with customers on
performing analytical validations on
this um but we we can work on custom
panels right so this is not a an
exclusive list
it's really just showing the different
um ads and panels that we have worked
with and consult with customers but
ultimately
as i mentioned we can do any custom
panel as well ultimately it's the
laboratory that decides what they want
to include in their clinical menu
so just as a as a recap
our
value proposition well we have really
spent a lot of time and effort into
looking at the regulations
the standards that apply on a regional
basis
and then
what that what we can put together that
translates into
accelerating that process of onboarding
a
new assay or panel into your clinical
menu we have some
references here that are pretty sure
will be very valuable as you
really engage into this process and look
at what you need to do within your
organization uh to set up um
this type of
assays and bring them in and and
complete a calculation
and uh we deeply uh thank you for this
opportunity and uh to have this
conversation thank you so much
thank you raphael for sharing those
experiences and insights into the av
journey as well as the need for
analytical validation
this concludes our presentation for
today
please be sure and check back regularly
for new webinar series or to view any of
the presentations from today or the
previously broadcasted webinars on
demand here in the auditorium thanks
again to rafael and everyone who
participated in this presentation we
hope you enjoyed today's event and look
forward to seeing you again soon
you